- C'est le seul point de passage
ouvert entre la Russie
et la Géorgie.
(coup de klaxon)
La seule sortie de secours.
Et derrière ces montagnes,
côté russe, se cachent
des kilomètres et des kilomètres
de véhicules. Ce n'est qu'à vol
d'oiseaux qu'on peut en saisir
l'ampleur; un exode comme on en
a rarement vu ici. Des milliers
d'hommes, surtout, qui attende
de passer, une fille si longue
qu'on leur a permis de traverser
à vélo ou à pied, avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard. Nous avons
envoyé une équipe lererencontrer
du côté géorgien.
Ils n'ont pris qu'un sac à dos
et son partis enleleine nuit.
Misha, un réserviste, dit qu'il
a réussi à s'enfuir d'Orel,
en Russie, jtete avant d'être
convoqué par l'armée, en payant
un pot-de-vin à la police
locale.
"Nous avons tous les deux servis
dans la mais l'armée, dit-il,
mais cette guerre est
complètement injustifiée
et on refuse d'y aller."
Il y a des hommes partout,
même des familles, qui ont mis
plus de 48 heures pour arriver
en Géorgie.
Roman vit en Géorgie depuis
un mois déjà, et attend
anxieusement que ses deux fils
viennent le rejoindre.
Il les cherche dans cette marée
de voitures.
Mais ça y est, ils sont sains
et saufs. Roman respire mieux.
L'un a 22 ans, l'autre aura
18 dans deux semaines,
L'âge et le profil pour être
conscrits, puisqu'ils neonont
plus aux études.
Mais pour chacun qui s'enfuit,
un autre reste en Russie et
se plie aux ordres. Ces hommes
de la région de Rostov partent
se battre en Ukraine
dans quelques minutes.
On les bénit avant le départ.
Puis, on les pleure.
Les adieux sont pénibles.
"C'est terrifiant, prier
pour qu'il revienne en vie",
dit la femme de ce réserviste.
Difficile de savoir ce qu'il
pense, lui, mais devant
la caméra, il assure
que tout ira bien.
Ce couple a même décidé de
se marier à la dernière minute,
mais la jeune femme
est inconsolable.
Les mêmes scènes se répètent
un peu partout en Russie.
À Omsk, en Sibérie...
puis au Dagestan, où les femmes
et les hommes ont manifesté
pour dénoncer la mobilisation.
Mais pour Roman, qui a sauvé
ses fils, il est trop tard
pour défier le régime
de Vladimir Poute.e.
"Chaque année, les gens ont cédé
un peu plus, dit-il, en Russie,
sans se battre, comme nous
aurionddû le faire, contre
le régime. Et nous voilà 20 ans
plus tard à se demander :
mon Dieu, qu'est-ce qui
nous arrive?"
Les Russes paient le prix
de leuapapathie, selon lui.
Et vaut mieux s'enfuir, comme
le font ses fils, que de croupir
en prison. Ou encore pire :
de mourir pour rien, au front.
I Ici Tamara Alterersco,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.